all right if this isn't the cuniest
ever I don't know what is come here mama
come with taika
CUNY
are you guys ready yeah
but it's brand new sit in there this is
for the road trip
can you see good job but he just wants
to test it I think
I do hey good job what a good boy that's
safe there you go oh yeah hey you can
see the road now
that's the best you big CUNY is that
cool or what we're gonna see so many
cool places and you can have the best
view ever yeah
yeah is that not the cutest thing you
ever remember that cute yeah
so yeah that is one of the cuniest
things ever on the box it actually says
big kids too so they let you know that
the Mr Hooters
is a big kid see look
for your big kid four to ten years old
hey whose booty is that got a boot 10
years old yeah you're about to be six
isn't that crazy bones but does it say
five years old I know this is four to
ten which means you're included
she's 10 years old yeah how do you know
she is pretty tall
yeah
oh you're bringing a Spider-Man hat we
got all our stuff packed ready to go
Mama's luggage yep
oh that's smart Papa does that too
sometimes when I'm traveling because I
don't want to lose track of my hat so I
hook it right there good job that's a
smart move mister
I gotta go pack my truck
yeah right here this is type of stuff
you got type of stuff right here yeah
papa stuff right there
Mama stuff right there
for the road and I got protein chips
because I'm still on a diet
are you happy mister I'm going on a road
trip
yes
your collection oh tell them you tell
them my voice is dead no no I like
hearing your voice sounds sexy or raspy
so we decided to buy a new cooler
and this cooler we're gonna take this
with us on all future road trips
and we're gonna start adding stickers to
it of all the places we're going so we
started off with red Red Rock Canyon
because we go there all the time but
this is our cool little Yeti cooler it's
like a slate blue looks super dope wish
it was a brand deal but it's not it's
okay
um but we're packing it full of
um just like some like mill meal
in-betweeners meal in betweeners I'm
calling it that because
um we're gonna be
so we planned this road trip a little
bit last minute ideally I wanted to get
like an RV and stuff but you got to book
a lot of things in advance and then you
got to prep before because you got to
get all the food for the whole week so
instead we're gonna do a regular road
trip where we just drive from hotel to
hotel to hotel but when you're with the
kid and when you're on a diet it turns
into a giant kid
um sometimes you need the meal in
between like I was talking about so uh
we want to have some sandwiches some
fruits some peanut butter jelly uh
Smuckers things that way if we're ever
in a pinch like we wake up in the
morning and uh the hotel breakfast
section isn't open yet you know Antica
has a seizure medicine where he has to
take two medications we don't want him
just sitting there in the morning with
two medications down the tummy already
because he has to take one at pretty
much like 7 A.M in the one to seven PM
so we always want to have something in
his tummy so we have all our meal
in-betweens like the snacks and the road
trip stuff and even for me because
um I'm on a diet I know how easy it is
for me to get tempted so to prepare for
that I actually
um pre-made some protein that I can pack
away that way if I need to I have like a
quick meal so check it out I got some 90
7-3 lean beef
pre-cooked it this morning each one of
these guys is eight ounces so if I need
to hit like a quick 40 50 grams of
protein
I have them right here I'll just put
them in the cooler and
um that way I'm able to resist
temptation a little bit more while uh
probably like reducing some of the carbs
that I typically eat so the goal is to
still go on a trip have fun but because
I'm prepared I won't lose track of my
fitness goals
all right got everything packed nicely
inside got the ham the strawberries got
I found these guys dude 97 3 fat free
it's only one gram of fat with six grams
of protein
oh thank you for another ice pack we got
ice packs at the bottom you see that
when we get hurt you can use it
is your heart right there did you bump
your head this morning
all right so we got ice packs put this
down here
and then also
um got a extra bag of ice just in case
there we go look at that
CUNY
you ready to go on your road trip
I'm also really excited because Mia's
coming with us so every hotel that I
booked I made sure that it was pet
friendly so that she doesn't have to get
a babysitter anything we get to enjoy
our road trip together
if this isn't the cuniest thing in the
world I don't know what is look in the
back and we got little me in the back
CUNY
so our first stop is going to be Death
Valley
and uh but before we get there we got to
get some food because we're starving and
we haven't we wanted to leave the house
with the empty fridge so we didn't cook
anything because you know like if we're
gone for like a whole week things could
smell bad in their fridge and it could
go bad so we didn't want to do that so
so you can throw up why would you want
to throw up
you're disgusting hey what the you
putting germs on me all right first stop
a little drive-through before we go on
our trip and I love love tailgating
I don't know what the word is it feels
cozy comfy grassrootsy or something like
that but we got Mr Man up there with
this kid's meal oh yeah we got mama with
her meal
and I got my diet version I subbed the
delicious fries and the bread for extra
coleslaw and people don't know but the
breaded chicken because it's white meat
it's actually not too bad so I can eat
this and I'll probably have a carbless
dinner and pound a double protein shake
and I'll be fine and we got Mia down
here ready waiting for the scraps
all right now we got my bear scraping up
all the dog fur
from this young lady thanks dude because
as you guys know
for taika seizures number one thing from
preventing them is Apple sleep so now
that we're gonna get on the road it's
noon time which is his nap time so we're
trying to set up like a really CUNY
comfy nap station in the back where he
can lay down and get some like deep
sleep versus like having them sit up in
like uh like a kid's normal chair where
he has to like
balance like that you know you never
really get deep sleep like that so you
want them to like lay down where he can
like pretty much pass out and really
feel like uh he's just in his bed and so
that's what I wanted to wait until we're
about to get on the freeway where it's
just technically a straight line no
twists and turns and so we're setting up
his little bed right now
oh look at this big booty
yes
yes slip it oh you know the tricks you
young man you little feisty young man
so the first thing that we did since we
have all kinds of luggage is uh we
bungee corded everything so it doesn't
fall over and squish him as he's
sleeping but yeah we got all this bungee
cord
and it's connected down there where the
railings are so I mean this looks pretty
good
okay monkey get comfy
there you go take off for sure hoodies
there you go good job
okay put your little head head right
here no I want to take this off it's too
hot
does it feel hot mister
I mean this one I want um
okay there okay now get comfy because
after you get comfy I'm gonna bring me
in well that's pretty comfy does he get
a little blanket Mama yeah it's right by
his head okay
there you go okay get comfy and then
we're gonna tuck you in
oh that's very common oh there you go
good job
oh that's comfy right there
at least it has to feel like this I'm
gonna have to sleep like my pizza are
gonna be like yeah I'm Papa's gonna need
like a Hummer to do that oh look
Michael's gonna be here I'm right in
this place is gonna be down there yeah
but now and it's just a big open field
most of America looks like this
road trips and that's what makes it so
peaceful but that peacefulness is also
reflected in here because both Mia and
taika knocked the f out like I could
hear tiger snoring
[Music]
so I looked up a couple of things to do
at our destination which is uh Death
Valley
uh there's Death Valley National Park
which has like a 14 Mile Trail like you
drive through and you can see like a
cliff you can see all kinds of cool
stuff but there's also sand dunes so I
feel like Tycho would love that I like
to see big positive sound like like an
Egyptian desert I think you can do it so
we're gonna go there first especially
catching it at Sunset I think it'll be
really really cool
all right
all right all right first stop the sand
dunes and this looks insane
did you see the sand dunes
does it look crazy does it looks like
we're in Egypt
how was your nap by the way Mister is it
comfy yeah
look at that holy moly
yeah it looks crazy
wow
hey monkey what is that in front of us
real one huh
we live in the fake one
that's Rocky down here
that's Rocky
is it let me see whoa that's fine
look at this there's like a hard Edge
on this dirt isn't that crazy oh yeah
but it just breaks right off
what
okay it is like we're in Egypt
wow
get him here let me get it Mia thinks
that's an animal come come come get it
come on man get it get it there you get
it get it
get it get it get it girl you Brave
whoa look how cracked this is look
that's crazy
you could do it dude you could do it
dude
you're almost there
yeah I think she likes it
yeah come Mia come here
whoa you're so fast
look how close we came to the big Dunes
so our truck
I'll be over there a little white dot
came out over here
big dude
still over there
we're probably not gonna make it all the
way because Tiger's been coughing up a
storm
let's probably just chill out and relax
but look at this beauty
Persian princess right here
hey kidney
all right so this is freaking crazy I'm
just following the GPS this has never
happened before
but the GPS put us on a dirt road look
at this
Airport Road I have to be on it for 3.3
miles per hour I'm on the 95.
have you guys ever followed GPS and it
put you on a dirt road has this ever
happened to you Mama
um on a dirt road no right it's usually
paid yeah I've never had GPS tell me to
go off-roading before
which is kind of cool
but it's also insane
you have your lights I don't know look
if I don't have my life this is just my
headlights that's actually headlights on
it doesn't look that bad on camera it
looks actually brighter really okay
[Music]
this is Adventure monkey I hope you know
this is Adventure
there's
so we're literally in the middle of
nowhere
like if you look it's just darkness
infinitely that way
then Darkness infinitely that way
Darkness infinitely that way
and then there's this random Casino
slash in
called Long Street casino and Inn that
I'm actually really really grateful for
because Expedia Mama they got a lot of
good reviews here and I was kind of
scared because you know things in the
middle of nowhere are never too good
but I can't wait for you to go inside
because you'll see how convenient it is
for family Travelers and it's pet
friendly
okay you ready responsible for your
stuff
go
so look how cool this place is Mama
there's even a small Supermarket right
there
so if we need water milk anything in the
morning and then that's the restaurant
closes at 10. and then you can have
entertainment pretty cool right our room
is down that way down that Hall
okay look at all the stuff they have in
here instant noodles Fountain drinks
pre-made sandwiches
super convenient so in the morning we
could just wake up grab and go maybe
even pack some of the stuff that we need
to refill a little cooler but given that
they have a restaurant I don't even
think we're gonna have to eat anything
that we have in the cooler which is good
so now that we can use it oh wow they
even have a little laundromat
maybe a little laundromat
this place is sick
and it's pet friendly did I say that
already yep
Mia's first time in the elevator
are you scared no she doesn't even know
we're in the room
oh yeah she could talk
okay let's go mister before the things
um close on us
don't work
no she was helping you
this
just checked into our hotel room
pretty nice
right yeah it's like old school but it's
like well organized clean I always check
this see if there's any body hairs nope
and we get to bring a little CUNY young
lady
and we got a sink right there
so we had a long day what we're gonna do
is I'm probably gonna go down a
restaurant order some food for to-go
while my bear gets tiger ready for bed
because we have a hard eight to eight
thirty um for him to go to sleep to help
keep the seizures at Bay it's been
working it's been going on almost four
months now it's usually so we're really
really happy about that so you want to
keep that going so even when we're
traveling can't really bend the rules
um and we'll see you guys tomorrow good
night